if I was really doing this right beside
me I'd make a thousand a week easy and
be like on just Saturday just working
Saturday to boost your income learn to
become from someone who has done the
thing that you want son what's up
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn how to make a thousand
dollars a week garage sale flipping with
Gary Vaynerchuk also if you want to know
a Gary Vee and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence checking my 250
for confident series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the reason people
don't put themselves in a position to
fail the reason people aren't patient is
they value other people's opinions too
much I think about garage sale that
really turns me on is the thrill the
hunt because it's the place where you
can really score a huge box of toys for
3 bucks or 300 here my carry on there
nearly 400
that much 15 bucks 30 but it like I
don't know usually
usually truly you only need about a
hundred bucks this could be a visa looks
a little too new but we're about the
strike they're striking to be done here
I'm not sure two stuffed animals mom Amy
how much is this
all right stuffed animals continue to be
my score 50 cents a pop Dumbo
disneystore snuffleupagus bang Olaf what
and this one's gonna be a beast the fao
schwarz
fao schwarz giraffe so we just looked it
up the the Jeffery giraffe Toys R Us FAO
Schwartz combo 30 bucks
you pay 50 cents and I'm nice to say
after a baby he's just like a quick 20
bucks just a lot of people not making 20
bucks an hour then just one of the
things wait till I look up to snuff love
you this
thank you so much exactly this is pretty
exciting to me the vintage Lego thing
never opened out 2003 Jesus I'm getting
old but still 15 years old excited to
open its up this was a huge score I
already looked it up paid 3 they wanted
5 paid 3 for these spider-man skates in
package never opened as well or open
pretty excited about it
oh don't worry that's so awesome fire
all right let's go she goes at least go
around the corner pull me so good so
good
Lego four zero nine eight twenty five
bucks give it to me little
all right pay two bucks for this all
right cool so some may see snow globes
yeah
and they are better than I think I
thought in a backpack
how'd you do ten if I bought three yeah
okay we have a bag I do have a bag
awesome this is an exciting
we just bought three snow globes for ten
bucks
and I'm fired up I'm fired up my guy
I'm fired up how do you feel feel really
good now starting to get hot getting
some stuff now well over $200 range
maybe a little bit more even feel much
better
hold on when you need it I liked
it's probably more let's see it says to
would you take a dollar fist yeah thanks
I picked up the scary bear for a dollar
called surreal from Tiger 2004 let's see
what it's worth 20 bucks all day fix all
day 20 bucks
excited about this and just picked up
two jerseys for two bucks apiece Kevin
Durant Seattle SuperSonics Jersey pretty
rare 2 bucks
Garnett really nice one actually
stitched Celtics 2 bucks each
we'll say sixty four bucks for the
Durant I mean you know pay two bucks you
saw my there's a little bit like show
you stains on it I can clean that off
just crazy if I was really doing this
right just I'd make I'd make a thousand
a week easy and if you'd like on just
Saturday just working Saturday so look I
mean I genuinely think goodwill eBay
buying bulk on eBay selling and I was
like I just think this is the hundred
thousand dollar a year thing there's so
many people making 30 to 60 thousand a
year
I feel phenomenal this is the big final
score it's about a hundred bucks minimum
and now I know about cherish Teddy's now
amateurish Teddy's player and every time
you become more of a player of a new
thing look this is very simple spent
forty fifty per twenty forty bucks 50
bucks easily now into the five or six
hundred dollar range of resale I just
wish so many of you would do this it's
four or five six hundred bucks every
weekend it's now 1147 so with four hours
in little gas money I get it but like
net net two three four hundred bucks
every weekend and if you don't want to
be like tedious because now you got to
post it all this cool just throw up this
huge collection of cherished Teddy's 80
bucks boom quick little you know sixty
bucks here adds up when you got
groceries when you got bills when you
got college loans when you got rent
people sitting around dwelling
eighty five ninety percent of this
country working you know minimum wages
low-income it just matters teaching
people how to fish live life it's real
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Gary given advice to a hustling
young lemonade stand entrepreneur that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
I want on your thoughts on this series
it's a new series I'm trying out called
make money where the idea is once a
month giving you practical advice and
tips from different entrepreneurs on how
to make money every day or every week
every month in different fields if you
like the idea let me know leave your
thoughts in the comments below
so disappointing that
I'll take a cup buddy
one cup please I'll keep the change
you're welcome you're welcome
gotta support the original hustle you
know what I mean look at the pouring
skills the extra lemons in this bowl is
really good marketing you know what I
mean
call my eye good job welcome if you want
more garyvee check out my top 50 rules
video the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there oh it's
so sad that all these kids can't
communicate because they're on the phone
anymore and you could talk about a day
and age when it was simpler and nicer
and all this